c'est vrai que stanislas et ses deux
acolytes sont un brin sadique mais vous
allez voir ce sont aussi de vrais petits
génies on vous accuse de sadisme parce
que vous l'avez fait passer un sale
quart d'heure à vos plantes là ici dans
ce jardin oui tout à fait dans le sens
où ici nous sommes en face d'une flore
dhombres de milieux forestiers qu'on a
placée en plein soleil
pas sympa non c'est pas très sain et
pourquoi vous avez vu ça alors on a fait
ça parce que on a essayé de répondre à
la problématique à la question du
biomimétisme à travers la problématique
du réchauffement climatique et du
dérèglement climatique d'accord donc on
a essayé de recréer un milieu tempéré à
l'aide de nos structures ici présentes
que vous pouvez voir qui
viennent s'inspirer en quelque sorte du
zèbre d'accord c'est vrai que lieu
s'appelle le jardin zèbres qu'est-ce qui
incarne le zèbre ici pourquoi en fait on
l'a appelé comme ça alors on l'a appelé
comme ça dans le sens où on a créé une
seconde peau c'est cette seconde peau
qui vient justement permettre à nos
plantes d'ombré de pouvoir vivre en
plein soleil et de supporter les grosse
canicule dont on est le plus souvent
soumis
c'est par là qu'on voit au dessus de ça
en fait c'est ça j'utilise le mot
pergola à juste titre ou pas c'est ça
c'est tout à fait ça ok et donc on s'est
inspiré donc des motifs du zèbre qui
selon des postulats scientifiques et des
recherches actuelles permettrait au
zèbre de thermo réguler sa température
corporelle par la savane
donc quand il fait très chaud grâce à
ses brûlures il va supporter la chasse
et ça et le froid de la nuit d'accord je
note que y'a plein de matériaux très
différents je sais que vous avez fait
des choix
bon là dessus des choix il perd engagé
les militants oui c'est ça alors dans
notre collaboration à tous les trois
donc etienne lorient et moi même on aime
choisir donc des matériaux de réemploi
donc comme on peut trouver sur ce sol
ici oui donc là ce sont des noyaux de
pêche ont recyclé dont tous les sirops
et tous les jus qu'on boit produit des
noyaux et c'est une entreprise donc il
est revalorisé pour remplacer les
gravillons ce qui nous entoure aussi ça
c'est quoi alors ça c'est du châtaignier
et châtaigniers qui viennent de nos
forêts françaises
le sol est constitué de brf donc c'est
du bois raméal fragmenté donc c'est tout
ce qui est broyé au tour qui est
réutilisé au niveau du sol et je crois
qu'en fait vous avez voulu faire un
jardin simple mais vous avez surtout
voulu vous amuser oui c'est ça on aime
vraiment faire des choses assez simples
assez direct surtout pour un festival
qui
ah c'est momentané en cas de besoin donc
c'est plutôt une installation et quand
on se retrouve tous les trois c'est
vraiment pour s'amuser